all right you want to make a give a big
shout out in a big thank you to everyone
who came out to opportunity villages
fall into fashion event this past
weekend oh it was fantastic they say
they they feel like they made more money
than ever before i had the
the real pride of being able to host
this year the paddle raises that's where
everybody was bidding extra on the ov
models and the trade and fashion
academy of las vegas helped the ov
models design all their own clothing we
had first responders representing the
southern nevada burn foundation who were
escorting the models on the runway again
this year and we paid tribute of course
to all first responders it was 9 11 on
saturday but what a huge success the
models all had such a great time man
they rocked those fashions hey dude
shoes mj christensen supplied all the
beautiful jewelry and the models were
just so excited and beautiful in their
outfits so wow thanks to everybody who
came and had a wonderful time it was
brunch and champagne and i love it lots
of money raised so congratulations
opportunity village and all the great
models just so proud walking down that
runway they look great